Super glad to have just sell
Carino here with us today. Um,
just sal is the CEO of the International
Planned Parenthood Federation in the
Western Hemisphere region and today we
really are going to have a conversation
about the state of women's health in the
state of women's rights in the region
and how the International Planned
Parenthood Federation is navigating the
regions, um, rapidly changing political,
economic and environmental landscape.
I am delighted to have a woman leader
here today to talk about this important
issue. So welcome so much.
Thank you for [inaudible]
introduction. Thank you all
for joining this conversation.
Thank you both John and [inaudible] for
making this company companies a great
opportunity to be here.
Coffee is great,
and I look forward to the next, to the
next opportunity. Thank you very much.
Good. Well, just all,
I always like to start these
conversations with the personal stories.
So can you tell us a little bit about
how you got interested in this work and
sort of how you got to
where you are today?
Well, I, you know, I grew up in Argentina,
in Argentina. And when I say rural,
I mean rural.
I remember receiving the Sunday
paper at 4:00 PM that's rural.
And, um, you know, I went to
an all girls Catholic school.
Um, we, and this is not a telecom
faith faces as you just mentioned. I,
I, we work with, uh, progressive, uh,
religious leaders and I'm part of the
board of Catholic for the right to decide.
But, you know, we, I remember
we used to be, you know,
girls playing on one side and
boys playing on the other side.
And I remember always asking the
question, why is this, you know,
I have brothers and cousins.
We used to play together and
things were different there.
And I remember the answers were not quite
satisfying. And then as I grew up, um,
you know, my parents would say like,
what do you want to be when you grow up?
And across the street there was,
um,
a farming school full of
boys and, um, and this,
I thought that was really cool.
You know,
like they used to be outdoors all the
time and said, I want to be a farmer,
I want to go to that school. And, and they
would be like, not real. That's, that's,
you know, for boys. Like
why is that? And again,
not a very satisfying answer to that.
And then I think all of it came together
when I was in secondary school and one
of my best friend got
pregnant and she wasn't,
I'm rejected from a school, but, um,
but she couldn't be part of us anymore.
You know,
like the social stigma associated
with teen pregnancy is huge,
continues to be huge. And, um, and so
I think all of it came together and,
and it was clear that it
could have been any of us,
that we needed the information to be
able to protect ourselves to live healthy
lives. And that wasn't there,
that wasn't available to us.
Right. Um, I also grew up,
you know, during the dictatorship
in Argentina. I was born in 19,
776 on in, and now, you know,
my age and the leadership
began in March of that year.
So I remember that crashing
sense of, um, that,
you know, things would never change.
And, um, and then when democracy came,
that feeling of it was in our hands to
make that happen and to protect that.
So I think,
you know,
all of it had to do with ended up where
I ended up in planned who do it worked
for women's right.
I truly believe that there isn't the
possibility of development without half of
their population being uh,
including um,
and sexual and reproductive
health and rights are key, right?
Deciding if we want to
have children when we have,
we want to have to live with whom is
critical to us being a full participant,
participants, um, in society. So all
came to everywhere. I love that. Well,
thank you for sharing your personal story
with us and I always appreciate that
because it sort of gives a sense for,
you know,
how you got to where you are today,
which I think a lot of people
always want to know about. Um,
tell us a little bit about sort of a
wide range of services that planned
parenthood does provide and sort of
white you're the population you serve,
looks like he has. Well, we, um,
last year alone serve about 6 million
women in lead in America and the Caribbean
and provided roughly 30 million
services from a really pap screening,
cervical cancer screening,
sexy location,
a gender based violence services,
access to contraception, um,
and safe and legal abortion
when that, when that is
allowed by the local laws. Uh,
one thing that I should mention is that,
you know, we're a global federation. Um,
so we have a presence in about 150
countries around the world. Um,
we represent the Latin America and
the Caribbean. We work with 40, um,
independent organizations,
non for profit organizations
that are affiliated to us. Um,
I don't know how many of
you do know, uh, of, uh,
Planned Parenthood Federation of
America. Many of you know, right? Yes,
they're great. There are a
great partner in the US. Um,
how many of you do know of I
BBF or International Planned
Parenthood Federation?
Probably not too many.
Right. It's, it's okay. Um,
Planned Parenthood Federation of America
is our partner in the U S and lady that
we have partners,
uh,
in 150 countries globally are so
many of them providing a full care,
comprehensive sexual and reproductive
health services for women and men.
About 10% of our services are to men.
And we got a big focus on youth.
Um, I across the world and in particularly
in Latin America and the Caribbean,
about, uh, 40% of our services
go to young people. Um, yeah.
And then a lot of those cases,
are you providing free or low cost health
care to the patients that come in your
door? Yes, we lose one. We not only
have clinics in many of the countries,
you know, that is a, a game
I like to play when I go.
I spend much of my time visiting clinics
and programs in Latin America and the
Caribbean. And, uh, when the
taxi driver picks me up from
the airport, I always ask,
so how do you know local clinics?
Have you been there,
your friends when they're,
and,
and the answers to those questions
normally is yes. Uh, they, uh,
they know our clinics because we've been
providing services now for 50 years, uh,
in the region, but we not only
provide the services in the clinics,
we also run community based programs down
in communities where other people will
then go. Right. Eh, and many,
all of our services are subsidized and
many of them are free of cost in these.
So probably in a lot of friends,
a lot of these women,
especially in rural communities,
that planned parenthood clinic might be
the only clinic that is affordable and
accessible for them.
Right. Indeed. Indeed. Yes.
So you've been with the
Organization for over a decade,
which is quite impressive.
Can you share what's changed in
that time over your service with the
International Planned Parenthood
Federation? Well, you know,
it's interesting because I transition,
um,
I am a first time CEO and transition
to become the CEO last year,
arguably not the best year to transition
anything called planned parenthood. Uh,
it's a, you know, full of challenges.
And I think my work before
was a programmatic work.
I spent time with women and,
and the communities.
And I think I saw a great
change in terms of, you know,
we have been able to lift many people
out of poverty in Latin America and the
Caribbean. We still remain as one of
the most unequal regions in the world.
Uh, that means that if you
are young, if you're poor,
if you're from an indigenous community,
if you're a for the [inaudible], um,
the way you experience life
health services, you're
needs are different, right?
Um,
most of our countries are considered
now middle income countries and uh,
this means that donors have
pullout from the region,
but huge pockets of poverty
and inequality remain. And, um,
and the people we serve are these people,
right?
So we need to continue investing in
this program and in the services.
Um, I think we know that we
have then great advances.
We have been there for 60 years.
We have brought contraception
to many of these countries.
Emergency contraception,
what is called the morning after pill.
It should be called the, as
soon as possible, Bill, because
you can use it up to five days
after having unprotected sex.
But the sooner you use it,
the better.
We brought that to many of the
countries in which we are working.
So we have made great
strides, um, in, um, you know,
bringing in contraception to women,
but we know that we have 23 million
women who want access to modern
contraception and don't have it.
Right.
So I think there have been
great advances in general,
but there are huge challenges that,
uh,
that remain and we have to
continue working to close
that gap for sure. You know,
in Silicon Valley here we're
technologists by and large.
And so we always think about the
role of technology in our work.
So has technology played a role in the
work of International Planned Parenthood
Federation? Yes, I think
we have made important than
investments in technology. I,
my, uh, seems small to you,
but we invested in making sure that we
have electronic health records across the
world so that we can not
only serve women better,
but also assess the health outcomes
over time. And that's an investment we,
we have done over a number of years now.
We think that are great opportunities
for technological innovations.
We are a region with high conductivity
and we have in front of us,
um, the largest generation
of young people ever. Wow.
Reaching them. Uh, it's a
huge opportunity, right? It's
a huge challenge as well.
And I suspect that we will know how to
help us close that gap because I think
probably technology has a key role to
play in reaching these people with both,
um, information, uh, it location
and actual actual services.
Um, unfortunately the, you
know, telemedicine, uh,
all of that is not as
developed as it is here,
but we do a follow very closely and,
uh,
love to try a few innovations that we
know are happening in the United States
right now.
And that hold great potential too,
to bring services to women in
a much more cost effective way.
How that's a fantastic opportunity for
all of us here to think about and be
involved with for sure.
So we do have a powerful
female CEO here in our midst,
and I always like to,
to ask you a little bit about what that
year has been like and what are some of
the key leadership challenges you faced
and the lessons you've learned, um,
in that year? Well, it's, it was,
it, it was clearly a tough year. Um,
not only, um, you know, we had
a new US administration, um,
not quite favorable to
our issues. And, um,
you know, everything that happens in
the u s has an impact, um, overseas.
Um, we, you know, the US used to have
a leadership role on these issues.
That's no longer the case. And, um,
prison term impose as soon as he
took office. The global gag rule.
Talk a little bit about that cause I'm
not sure everybody's familiar. Yeah. The,
everybody, a Republican
president since Reagan, um,
uh, put in place something
called the global gag rule,
which is limits the ability
of organizations overseas
that receive us funding,
um, to either, uh,
advocate for change in the laws and
policies in relationships to abortion,
to provide abortion services
with their own resources,
even if our version is legal
in that country. And, um,
and their money normally,
uh,
from the u s government was for
work lake access to contraception,
gender based violence.
Uh, what the was uh,
impose a rule of really unprecedented
proportions that in every source of
funding from, from the US government,
including tuberculosis, malaria,
HIV, AIDS. Um,
so normally about 600 million of us
falling assistant money would be gab,
um, as we call it. Um,
in this case is about
eight point $8 billion.
So this is a policy that has the potential
to really do serious damage to women
around the world.
Um,
we as an organization decided
not to be guided by these policy.
Um, we, you know,
we give up out $100 million
as an aside, as a holy, um,
uh,
and um,
and we think this rule is unfair and
unjust and harms women and really has the
potential of harming women
across the globe. So, um,
that was a big challenge. We face
as soon as I took, I took office in,
um,
I think in April last year we had Brexit
in July and we had the elections in
November and this happened right
after in January. So I think that's,
that was one of the biggest
challenge. Um, the second one, uh,
you might have heard we have a string of
natural disaster you have effect in the
region, um, over the past
few months. Um, again,
disasters of unprecedented
proportions. Um, you know,
our clinics have been badly
affected. Our teams. Um,
what is really amazing to
see if, you know, we had the
earthquake in Mexico, they,
after our teams, people in our,
our office lost their homes.
They show up to work to
provide care for women,
not in the clinics because the
clinics were damage on the streets,
whatever that was possible. They were
there to help women because we know, um,
that,
uh,
one of the things that happen when natural
disasters effect is that the needs of,
of women and girls are normally not
the priority, but life goes on, right?
People continue to need contraception,
people continue to need
a prenatal care. And, um,
and I think has been amazing to see,
um,
the level of response in spite of,
of such, such a difficult situation.
And maybe if, if I am allow a second
to talk about Puerto Rico because, yes,
please. For the record, you
know, it's a case that hurts,
hurts me because the tuition of
the island was dire before, um,
before the hurricanes
hit. And, uh, you know,
50% of the population living below
the poverty line, many of them women.
Um, and then, uh, we have the
hurricanes. And as you know,
the response from the
government, has it been, um,
limited, um, unsatisfying?
I don't know how to,
what objective to objective
to use to define it. And, uh,
and I feel like we have four
clinics, um, in the island,
none of which are up and running because
they'll steal because we don't have
electricity. We, um, uh, you know,
we raise funding to buy
generators, which is the way, um,
and if they go away for
generators to get there,
because obviously everyone is trying to,
to buy generators and you can't
keep them running all the time.
So that will have some limitations.
Gas is a problem accessing gas, uh,
two random, um, and you know, we have,
uh, we know the need is there. We have
the infrastructure to set of women.
We need help to get those clinics,
uh,
back in order and to provide the services
that are very much needed because no
one else will we be doing
that. Right. So, so it's,
I guess I plenty of help for the case
of Puerto Rico in which the response has
been with contempt. Yeah. And um,
and he's wearing matching myth.
No, I think that's a really good
point. And you know, as you point out,
it really has been such a
challenging year, you know,
from policy and politics and natural
disasters and I can tell that this work is
very personal and it's very emotional
and I really do applaud your bravery and
your courage and your leadership.
How do you sort of keep your staff and
your caregivers and your providers sort
of,
you know,
motivated to do this work in the long run
because it can be very challenging and
emotional and taxing.
Yeah, we um, hold tight to
the good things. You know,
these people are fighters.
They been fighting in the front lines.
These challenges are not new to us.
Our bigger, that's right. It's
always difficult but they,
our themes are there
serving the needs of women.
There is nothing more satisfying.
There is nothing more satisfying to me
and to many of them. Then when, you know,
when you sit with women
in the waiting rooms in,
when I travel and get to talk to him
and the number of barriers they had to
overcome to be there and you have
the answer to what they need,
there is nothing more satisfying
than being able to provide that. Um,
and I think that Colin tied to that is
what keep us going and the support of so
many of you,
you know,
we couldn't do this work
without supporters like you
who are there to hold the
line and, and support us every step of the
way. So thank you. Thank you very much.
You know, um, then thank you.
Thank you for motivating,
you know,
your team of caregivers and
providers to do this work.
It's really quite incredible.
You talked a little bit about how
oftentimes when a young woman gets to your
clinic,
they've overcome a lot of barriers just
to get there and be present that day for
their services.
Can you talk a little bit about
some of those barriers women face?
Yes. And we work to help them
overcome them. You know, like I'll,
I'll talk a little bit about
our cervical cancer work,
which I think is a good indication
of that. We, um, you know,
cervical cancer is still a killer in,
uh,
for women in Latin America
and the Caribbean and across
the globe and is caused
by a virus called HPV virus.
Um, there are many strains of,
uh, of the vitals, but two that
really causes cervical cancer.
And there is a vaccine that is a
very low in developed countries.
So we partner with the Ministry of Health
in Bolivia and our members association
there to bring the vaccine, uh, to,
to Latin America and the Caribbean.
And it was quite pricey at the moment.
And I'm normally here, you know,
women would, uh, take girls.
The vaccination ranges between I
think nine and 12 years of age. Um,
and, um, to the pediatrician, the
pediatrician would offer the vaccine.
The vaccine has three doses,
so you have to go three times a
year with your girl for the vaccine.
So when we began looking at
this program and knowing,
I mean many of the women we serve,
um, you know, working the fields, um,
selling food in the market, they can't
just take the day off to do these,
uh, they might not have enough money
to feed their family that we give.
They do so. Right. Um, so we, uh,
develop this initiative and um,
uh, apply the vaccines in a pilot
program in schools because we know a high
proportion of the girls are in school,
they don't need their mothers, their and,
and we have a very successful rates
of vaccination higher than any other
vaccination program in
this pilot initiative.
So we tried to bridge the gap because when
you work in low resource settings, um,
we have to be creative and disruptive
in the way we think through through
programming. Right? So
that has been a, I think,
a very good example of trying to find
people where, uh, where they are and, um,
and help them overcome the challenges,
uh, that they wouldn't have otherwise.
That's fantastic.
I want to talk a little bit about a real
issue in a real crisis. And our society,
which is the issue of sexual
assault. Um, you know,
we've seen movements like me to start
spilling out to other countries and we've
definitely been hearing just more and
more about the prevalence of sexual
assaults, sort of, um, two
women around the world.
How are you sort of thinking about that
work and thinking about educating girls
and women about sexual assault,
sexual violence, sexual harassment,
and the impact of those things
to them? You know, I come from
joining, which I'm one in three women
have suffered violence, you know, the,
um, I think if we have 25 countries
with highest homicide rates, uh,
feminist side we call them against women.
14 are in Latin America and
the Caribbean. Um, I um,
I think, um, I follow very
closely. Me Too. I think, um,
it's great. That is a lot in
women's story. Deli come in,
women coming forward and telling
their stories. Um, I think um,
it was very interesting to see how that,
um,
how that trickle effect and
about 12 countries. Um, you
have to love the French.
They call it out the pig
or something like that.
I mean it's just a fabulous, and
I think to see, uh, very quickly,
even in Argentina, a few days after
the waste end case in the u s uh,
we have a case, um, uh, on,
uh, for a journalist as well.
I think there is a lot of power in people
telling their story in coming forward.
This is not just about a solidarity,
it's about self exposure, right?
And four, we know those of us
who have worked in violence,
we know that for every woman that comes
forward there yet that are at least 10
that haven't.
And that is a of you know,
a pervasive element in our society.
Um,
also in Argentina we are
home of a movement called um,
new and our not one less.
This moment kind of happened organically
as a result of a number of super high
profile cases of, of
homicides against women, uh,
mostly by their partners.
And um, you know,
we are 40 million and they mobilize out
a million people in the first time that
they go together. Last year they mobilize
3 million people. And you could argue,
you know, Argentinians
like to march, but, um,
but I think that it was incredible.
The mobilization,
the digital mobilization. Many
people show up at work, uh,
dressed in black tomorrow to show
their solidarity. And I think,
I think that's amazing.
I think as a,
as a movement or I like to think
we are reaching a tipping point,
we no longer have to accept
these as part of our life.
And I think that is a lot of
transformation going on. And I,
if there is something to have faith
confidence on is in the ability of civil
society or follow fats,
um,
keeping this conversation going
because laws and policies will follow.
But we first need to understand that
this is simply not accept or we cannot,
we don't have to put up with this anymore.
And that's right.
That's the conversation that I saw going
on that gets me very excited because I
think it's the beginning of the end,
which was,
which is a terrific sort of optimistic
view and I really thank you for that.
You know, you said something that
really struck me, sad for everyone.
My man that comes forward and reports
a sexual assault or sexual violence,
there's probably 10 more that
haven't reported. You know,
how can technology or how can our work
help more women sort of be able to come
forward and get the help they need
and the support they need. Yeah.
I think it's what we are
seeing. You know, we,
we have been one of the first institutions
that created a health response to
violence. No. And I think with
technology, so much more can be done. Uh,
I think, uh, as I said,
there is a lot of um,
it's very powerful for women to come
forward and they have done so, um,
and a beer, you know, this
is a conversation happening,
the regular conversation,
everybody's is talking
about this. And I think, um,
technology's obviously a big part of
the cooling cap happen before, you know,
this is not, I support techs.
This is Mitchell. Yes, I am.
I am very much part of
this. And I think, um,
and I think it was possible because
of the connectivity and the platforms,
we have to be able to express ourself.
And I think that's a great thing.
That's a great thing. Yeah, for sure.
Tell us a little bit about
how International Planned
Parenthood Federation as
approaching HIV and
AIDS, um, the treatment,
the care or the awareness and the
region as well. Yeah, we have know, uh,
sexual rights and,
and the work around HIV AIDS have
been central to our work. Uh,
we integrated HIV detection services
across our region in Latin America and the
Caribbean.
I have gone to the communities work with
a specific population where the virus
tends to be concentrated in the region,
has been a critical piece of our work.
Um, luckily the, the, there has been
a lot of progress in the region, uh,
on that issue. And some of
our member associations even,
uh, provide treatment. Um,
one of them Dominican
Republic for instance.
So we have been fully involved over
the past 10 years in integrated service
delivery,
uh,
on HIV and feel very proud of
the accomplishments in that area.
It's wonderful.
And I want to turn a little bit to some
of the laws and policy in the region. So,
certainly even in the states,
we're seeing laws and restrictions
being passed that, you know,
make it harder to have access
to safe and legal abortion.
Are you seeing that as well? Um,
in Latin America and the Caribbean?
Thank you for that question because when
I talked earlier about service delivery
and location, and I forgot to
mention that we really work, uh,
around laws and policies
that inhibit access, uh,
for women's exercise of their rights.
Right?
We work at the local and the regional
and we also had the work at the UN on
behalf of IBM as a whole globally.
Um,
what we are seeing, um, in Latin America
we have a lot of laws and policies. They,
they issue a, the
hardest nut to crack, uh,
is in the implementation aspects of things
and making sure that the money exists
to support, um, uh, service delivery. Um,
we're still home to,
uh,
for countries who have a
total ban on abortion. And,
um, for those of you who
might not know what that is,
is that you can't access abortion
services in any circumstances,
not even to preserve your
own, uh, life. And, um,
so it's a big challenge. We have,
I remember the case of parents,
she was a 16 year old from the Dominican
Republic who was pregnant and had
cancer and her treatment for cancer was
denied because of her pregnancy would
put at risk to her pregnancy. And
in the Dominican Republic, uh,
along with El Salvador and
Nicaragua and Honduras. Um,
there are no exceptions. Um, so,
um, she laid, she'll, if she paid,
she paid with her life, the
congress, the still, um,
debating a bill to open
some legal exceptions,
eh, but, um, there is much
work to be done. Um, in,
in that regard, we have a number
of countries that have, um,
legal exceptions and the books,
but those have not materialized,
you know, in the life of women.
Um, they might exist on paper,
but the implementation of those,
um,
I guess offer often time
limited and oftentimes we are a,
one of the providers in those places in
which legal exception exists, uh, for,
for abortion care, for legal
abortion care for women. Um,
we should to up big window. We, um, uh,
there was a total ban on
abortion in Chilean. And, um,
we just, um, maybe, maybe I want to
say two months ago, we're able to,
uh,
pass a legislation that allows for
three legal exceptions to preserve,
preserve the life of the woman,
four cases of rape and incest and cases
of fetal malformations incompatible with
life. And, um, and you know,
the law is limited in scope.
It's only three circumstances.
It was legacy from the
Pinochet dictatorship. Um,
but it's a biggest step
forward with Chilean women,
uh, to be able to access, uh,
in these circumstances.
And we still have four more countries to,
to be able to, to overturn the total vans.
We have the gates, I don't know if you,
if you have heard or follow the news,
we have the case of El Salvador.
Women in El Salvador go to jail if
they are suspected of having economists
courage for 30 years.
So these are really
draconian laws, um, that, um,
that, you know, need, need to change
and um, and um, they need to be changed.
Definitely.
And so I imagine a lot of your work as
the CEO of the International Planned
Parenthood Federation and the Western
Hemisphere is working with policymakers
influencing lobbying for change.
How are you finding the receptivity to
these issues and their willingness to
understand the issues, learn and
adapt and change? You know, we have,
I think a great partnership with
the government. We have, you know,
local organizations that are leading
the work on the ground. Just like, uh,
BFAs Lee in the work here in the u s um,
that helps because the organizations
have been there for 60 years.
They have a reputation,
they know where we do. Um,
having said that these issues are hard.
And as I said,
it's not only just changing
the loss once they load change,
the real fight begins and the fight
is making sure that those services are
available to women. So we are also, um,
act as watch dogs for the
government to make sure that, um,
the laws are implemented
and quite importantly,
that there is funding to
support the provision of
those services in the, in the,
in the national budget. Because
at the end we, you know,
we are there to support
as long as much as we can,
but this needs to be part of,
of the country program.
And that's easier said than done. Right?
Uh, when, when it comes to the reality,
we have laws that have been on the
books for a hundred years now and uh,
and many of them, you know,
implementation is a, is a slow, um, it's,
it's, it's a hard fight,
but I think one was fighting
very much so.
I think you said something that probably,
it's definitely surprise me and
maybe some of our audience too,
is that there's a big difference between
getting a law passed and the practical
implementation of it.
And I think sometimes as activists,
we think our work is done
when the law is passed, right?
It's a law is passed and change magically
happens. And I think you're saying, hey,
there's actually a long road between
a law on the books and practical
implementation on the ground.
Are there steps that can be taken to sort
of shorten that gap between passing a
law and practically implementing
it for the folks you serve?
Yes, we think, you know,
we're experience, you know,
working with health care teams as the
low in building the support for the new
low.
It's critical because you've got to have
providers query to provide services not
only ready, uh, ideologically
ready technically. Right.
Um, so I think we have learned
that if you engage, uh,
healthcare providers from the get go,
not only they work with women every day,
they know their stories,
they can bring their stories,
stories to the public
conversation, right. Um,
but also,
um,
they are the ones who will have to provide
services and that has proved to be,
I think an important element that we have
learned through the work we have done
in the region.
Yeah. That's very
insightful. Thank you. John.
I just wanted to take a
look our check with you.
Are there questions from the Dory?
I certainly have a lot
more for just solve that.
I want to make sure the
audience gets correct.
These have a couple, right?
One of the bully asks,
I used to work in public
health in Subsaharan Africa.
One of the challenges I encountered
was combating dangerous myths about
reproductive and sexual health.
How do you correct these
misconceptions in the field?
And is there anything that we have
Google can do to combat this type of
misinformation?
Of course.
I mean,
I think we heard it all right in
terms of myths and misconceptions.
Our contraception, I would
everything else. Um, I think, um,
I could not stress enough the need to
have comprehensive sexuality education
for,
um,
for young people and as early as
that is possible and not any type of
comprehensive sexuality education,
but one that its evidence base that
talks about power and relationships that
helps kids,
uh,
young people in maneuver the life and
the relationships and to calibrate them
challenge,
you know,
the social norms around masculinity that
offering oftentimes the basis for my
Cheeseman and for violence. Um, I
think, uh, that that's critical.
I think you at Google can
help. Um, as I said, we have,
um,
the VUS opportunity ever.
We have the largest generation of
young people in front of us. Uh,
reaching them with the right information.
Um,
it's critical and I suspect you will
have ideas on how you help us do that.
Um, but it's definitely something that
will be an investment that will pay off in
the next 40 years. We know
a location base off, um,
comprehensive sexuality education
is not the exception to that.
We have plenty of evidence, uh,
of the dipole of, uh, sexuality,
location that works.
Um, and I think we, uh,
we just need to be able to reach kids
in a school out of school early, uh,
with good information so they can
actually live the lives they, uh,
they want to leave. Um, and I think
it's, um, it's critical that we do that.
That's a great question. Thank
you. Molly. Another one. John,
can you talk a bit about how you evaluate
your programs for effectiveness? Yes.
We, uh, you know, for every
program we run, we, uh,
we do an evaluation of the programs.
Um, also, uh, you know, uh,
each member association runs, uh,
evaluation of own programs as well.
Evolution is critical for learning
for us. And, and I think, um,
the program I was talking about in
Bolivia on cervical cancer is again,
a good example because we not only
look about, uh, effectiveness.
Is the vaccine effective, it's
effective in this setting. Um,
we also look at are there better ways,
are there most cost effective
ways of doing that? Um,
one thing that we are very happy to
know now is that the vaccine that I was
talking about to prevent cervical cancer,
um,
instead of having three
doses has to those doses.
Being able to deliver a program
with two doses as opposed to three,
my seem a small thing.
It's actually a huge thing
because in low resource settings,
if you can eliminate one step, keep the
same results, you can use that money, uh,
for other, uh, health pressing
needs, uh, in the country. Right?
So we, uh, we'd love to do much
more, but we have a commitment to,
to evaluate everything. Everything we do.
That's fantastic. And I want to share,
we haven't touched too much on yet
as maternal mortality and I'd love to
understand sort of the prevalence or
the demographics in your region around
maternal mortality and sort of the,
a little bit about the harm reduction
that sort of really helps address the
issue. Can you talk to us about that? Yes.
It's, um, thank you for that question.
You know,
the harm reduction model was developed
in Norway about 10 years ago and,
uh, by a group of midwives and doctors
who worked in a public hospital. And,
um,
maternal mortality was always relatively
low in would away with one exception,
which was maternal mortality
view to unsafe abortion. Um,
and you know, what happens in,
in the region is that if you are,
um, you know, a woman of
means a, even though the law,
my, um, may not allow
for, for legal abortion,
you can get an abortion from your doctor.
Um,
the problem is that those who are not
women of means simply die right from
unsafe abortion.
So this is what they face in the
way they thought at the moment that,
you know, abortion was restricted.
There were a few exceptions,
not really known by women and not
really used by providers either.
Um,
and I Callum moment,
but it also has a before and
an after where women have, uh,
contacts with their providers and doing
nothing wasn't what they wanted to do.
Right.
So they develop a model that allows
them to educate women about what they
shouldn't do if they decided to
pursue, um, and abortion, uh,
what not to insert the
warning signs. Um, and also,
uh,
to come back for care afterwards.
They couldn't probably
help them in the moment,
only if they were eligible
for the legal exceptions.
Otherwise they didn't have the,
the ability to help them but help them
with education and they could come back
for care when they need care possible.
John is legal in all of the countries.
Um, and, and, and they thought this
was a very important, at the same time,
um,
there was a new drug called misoprostol
that became available in the region and
it's a, a drug that saves life, you
know, women can induce abortions.
It's much more, much more safer. And
so providers would advocate women, uh,
on how to use misoprostol.
They couldn't tell them where to get
misoprostol or the coolant prescribed a
drug. But, um, based on the
right to access information,
um,
you know,
they thought women should have access to
the best information to preserve their
lives and this is how they build the
model. And quite interesting, um,
the model was expanded to
several countries in Latin
America and in Africa and,
uh, they drove maternal mortality
to zero and in a matter of 10 years.
Um, and um, they also pave the way. Um,
I think for abortion law
reform would away in 2012, um,
you know, pass a law that decriminalize
abortion up to 12 weeks, uh,
in the country. And I'm absolutely
convinced that talking to women,
educating providers was key to build
support around the needs of follow that
would allow women to, uh, to manage
this part of their lives. Um,
we'd safety and with good health
outcomes. Um, so I think some other,
uh, it was portrayed in
the New York Times and,
and very much we are proud of
that they, they were able to, to,
to create and how a role to play,
uh,
in such a moment in women's lives are
certainly getting maternal mortality down
to 0% is an amazing feat.
So thank you for that.
Um,
you know,
we talked a little bit about the laws
and the restrictions that you're seeing
sort of come up in Latin America and the
Caribbean, but talk a little bit about,
you know, certainly in the u
s over the past several years,
there've been a lot of
restrictive laws passed,
making it harder to access contraception,
access safe and legal abortion.
How does sort of the policy in the
United States and the arguments and,
and politics sort of around women's health
impact the work you do in the region?
Yes, I, you know, the US used to be a
place where we look up, looked up for,
for leadership on these issues. And, and
as I said, that's no longer the case. But,
um, in addition to that, um,
and in addition to the global gag rule
that I talked before the really coattails,
um, uh, the possibility for
organization to serve women, um,
I say that what we're beginning
to see is a much stronger, um,
violent and aggressive or position
in the region, which is quite new.
We had not seen that before
in a matter of a few months.
We had,
you know,
our office as vandalize
in one of the countries,
our executive director in another country
with death threats and things that we
clearly had not seen before.
Um,
we also have something
that came up in Columbia.
There is called the gender ideology,
um,
a whole reframing conversation around.
Um,
and it came right at the moment
of the peace process. Um, and um,
and against all of our issues
really a very strongly,
and I think we, um, we
have to think about, um,
as a clear influence.
There has been some reports recently I
think in the Guardian about the role of,
um,
the opposition in the u s funding the
opposition in many of the Latin American
and Caribbean countries.
And I think we are going to see
more of that in the years to come.
So really the work we all do in our
individual regions and countries really is
interconnected.
And so playing a role to actively
advocate for policies that advance women's
health are important for all of us. Yes,
absolutely. Very much so. Very much.
John,
any last questions from the dory is,
I asked to sell just a few last important,
just one last one,
which was a lot of the conversation around
planned parenthood is on the topic of
abortion. But, uh, I understand you put
an awful lot effort into other kinds
of services. Well, could you perhaps
touch on a couple of those? Um, yes, we,
I mean, I've worked on, if you look at
our annual report, our chancery, cause I,
we're 5% of the services we provide.
Um,
about 30% are services on contraception,
um,
uh, cancer screening, a gender
based violence. Uh, both, uh,
detection screen and, and support.
So when you look at, um, um,
our, the number of services we
provide and the division, um,
you'll see that it's a very
small proportion. We feel
very proud of the work.
We do a on abortion version, but
we do, uh, much more, uh, indeed.
And, um, and you know, as I said,
we have been leaders in accessing,
in bringing contraception to Latin
America and the Caribbean and have done so
for about 60 years now.
So yes,
we provide comprehensive care to women.
We feel we need to serve the
needs of women, all of them, um,
with no exceptions, uh, when it comes
to reproductive and sexual care.
And that's how we stand
as an organization.
And that can be easily verified by hour,
by hour.
Annual report hasn't changed
much over the years. Really.
I think that's a great reminder of the
resources available to us to learn about
planned parenthood and the
wide range of work. You all do.
So at Google here we're coming
up on our annual giving week. Um,
Googlers are very involved in giving
back to the communities we serve.
And communities around the world
through our time, through our money.
What is the best way for a Googler who
is interested in women's health and um,
you know, reproductive freedom. What is
the best way for Googlers to get involved?
Well, first, thank you.
[inaudible] we feel your lab.
We are really very capital account
with us. One of our supporters.
I think the first thing I would say become
a supporter, you know, um, donate to us.
You can do so through our website.
Um,
IPPF whr.org this is the moment if it is,
if none of the agreements before convince
you, this is the moment to double them,
uh,
on women's right to reach the birth to
support all of the progressive causes.
There is no best time to do that.
Uh,
that now because so much is
it's under threat, right? Um,
we, uh, we just learned that you
also have a program, uh, that uh,
you can spend your time with us.
We would love,
I think you have a lot of ideas and
thoughts that could be very useful to us.
Um, and I think finally, you know, again,
you can help us bridge the gap in the
most difficult issues we are facing and
will make a difference in the
next 50 years, uh, in the region.
So I love to engage in a conversation
or how that could happen accessing young
people, um, uh, you know,
working together to be able to,
to enable that. Um, so I think there are
many ways in which, and, and of course,
collaborating and supporting your
local planned as well. You know,
we're a global movement and the
support is needed everywhere. Yeah,
that's fantastic. So I want to
end on a positive note. You know,
you did talk about it. It's a challenging
time for women's reproductive rights,
for issues of health care,
for sexual violence and
assault. But in talking to you,
I can tell that you have a lot of hope
and a lot of optimism for a better future.
And can you tell us sort of maybe a story
or share a few thoughts about sort of
how you keep that hope and optimism?
I'm alive in this work,
which is so important. It's
difficult than your, that automation,
which shave them feel
necessarily this way. Um,
I think we have to keep an
eye on the long fight, right?
We've been here for 60 years.
We'll be here for 60 more.
We are not going to
give up on women and um,
and we have seen the change that
happened. Right. And if you, if one keeps,
keeps their eye on the, on that long game,
um, we know things are possible and, and,
and change will come. It will require a
lot of effort. Uh, it's tobacco fourth,
it's never a straight line to the finish.
There is never a finished right. But,
um, but I have, I the confidence in the
role of civil society organizations,
you know, organizations like ours
who will not give up. And, um,
and I think it's very clear to us that,
that this is a fight worth fighting, if
anything. So yeah, that keeps me going.
Well, just sell. I've gotta tell you,
I think you instilled a great deal
of hope and optimism for me today,
certainly.
And I know for our audience members,
and I just want to thank you
for that. I think, you know,
we touched on a lot of issues today and
I think really gave cooglers listening
in the world,
listening,
a sense of sort of some of the issues
that we're facing and the importance of
getting involved.
So I just want to thank you.
We're very grateful for you and
your knowledge and most importantly,
your hope and your optimism. So
thank you so much. Thank you so much.